hello everyone this is Amir here from Audio
Science Review you all asked for more debunking
videos sorry here's another one uh it's this whole
category of usb filters and what are fondly called
the crapper fires i think that's an industry
term these days uh it makes sense right you take
a computer usb port hooked up to a deck computer's
busy doing a ton of things which it is and that it
surely must generate noise that then finds itself
into a deck and pollutes the output of the deck
you could say that's noise it adds jitter
takes away detail and what have you so uh
manufacturers know this and uh for last i don't
know seven or eight years they've been building uh
these filters i think one of the earliest ones was
this Audioquest jitterbug very very catchy name
very clever marketing you can see i was
a early adopter buying mine back in 2015
i buy them so you don't have to uh i'm
fascinated that they sell multi-packs of this
you can buy one or three or five and i believe
they advertise you should use more than one and
that you not only pass your uh dac output
through this but you also plug it into the
other usb ports you have on your
computer and snuffs the noise out of them
um assuming they think that they're all
shared ports on the same usb controller
which may be but uh and i've seen people
string a whole bunch of these things and
different brands where they put like five or
six of these things in series and of course
every time they add one the sound improves so they
add another one had another one add another one
so uh our challenge is to find out if these things
uh improve the sound or not and so let's take into
a review that i did of the jitterbug it's actually
the second time i've reviewed it and measured it
this what it looks like if you go down here
you'll see that it says it remove reduces
jitter and packets resulting distortion that
causes flat and irritating sound if you get
packet errors you will know it it'll buzz crackle
i mean you basically have a chunk of kilobytes of
data from your audio is just taken out so the
waveform will go like this and then it'll be a
chopped out section it will not result in any of
the things they're talking about it won't sound
flat it just sounds awful and in the short lengths
that we use usb cables for you know typical home
views this is absolutely not a problem once it
becomes a problem this won't fix it anyway you'll
need a repeater or some other method to extend the
length of usb cable and but anyway the rest of it
if it results in distortion we measure distortion
if it results in noise we measure noise if it was
results in sierra we measure jitter that's what
we're here for so um how to test it i took a
topping d50s uh one neat things about topping
neat or for this case is that it has a separate
nine volt adapter in there so let me see if i can
find it yeah so sorry a 9 volt connector but it's
really a usb plug so they give you a little
cable that goes from this power port to a usb
that powers it and you can either power it with a
you know your own phone charger what have you then
it's got a data port that you use to actually
communicate with it so we get to plug in an
experiment with the um jitterbug on on both ports
see if it makes difference on one or the other
because there's a theory as to whether the data is
noisy on usb or it's the uh data bus that's noisy
or both so let's go back to our measurements so
here i plug it in in series with the power port
and measure the output of the dac remember that's
the only thing we're interested none of us listen
to a usb cable by sticking in our ears this usb is
carrying digital data we need to convert that to
analog and all we care about at the end of the day
is what comes out of our dac not what goes in it
what goes in it is the designer's problem so if we
measure the uh d50s and take a wide spectrum of of
one kilohertz tone so this is our desirable tones
and all this other stuff is unwanted but they are
very very low level and uh we compare it with
uh topping by itself in in red and then topping
uh with 50s with with jitterbug plugged into it
and as you can see the two graphs just land on top
of each other there is absolutely no reduction
in noise we had all this noise it could get
rid of we could had all this distortion that it
could get rid of and it got rid of none of those
let's connect it on the data bus and see what
that does and this time i'm zooming into just 20
kilohertz bandwidth and again stuff just lands on
top of each other no matter how we plug it in and
so clearly no distortion was taken away you can
see all these little bits of noise in here surely
if it reduce any noise those little ticks should
have at least gone down but no even measuring down
to minus 150 decibels 160 decibels it makes no
difference and uh another test i ran which is just
everything's plugged in the way it is but
i don't turn on a stream of audio to the uh
to the dac so we're just looking at residual
noise that's on the analog output of the dac
and again we tested with other quests on you know
whether it's on power or whether it's on data
notice that the background noise is the background
noise there is no difference whatsoever so
what is filtering dilutes this testing
at least so someone may say well
maybe it doesn't work on that deck maybe it
works on another deck so i once one step lower
at the time uh topping d10 one of my favorites
i think was like 60 deck at the time and surely
this is a noisier less performant deck than
the topping d50s and and see what we get there
so here we look at our usual dashboard
now instead of just the zoomed in spectrum
uh remember this cyan ad is noise and distortion
and there are around one uh 105 or so depending on
you know which channel you look at 2.109 volts
coming out of it we plug in the jitterbug and
what do we see uh still 105. still 2.11 volts no
difference in the spectrum over here in FFT look
up here you see these three pulses for example
and identical performance i mean it couldn't
be more the same than it is so it's absolutely
absolutely absolutely not making a difference
um i run the same FFT that i ran before and while
the little variation here that's just happens you
know these things are random noise being picked
up and what have you but jitterbug just doesn't
do anything if you look over here it's just all
identical the two curves land on top of each other
but maybe not of the top index benefit from
this list switch brands to ifi idsd dac it's a
lower performing dac yet again his cyanide is only
down to 93 or 94 db and uh this is with it hooked
up direct we see the distortions sort of go from
highest to lowest here and uh we plug in jitterbug
what happens nothing so you know the exact same
sign add is still there the output voltage is the
same all the same distortions there's not a sign
of anything happening in here so might say wow
maybe these DACs aren't sensitive to noise on
usb bus if you had such noise then this would
improve it my classic answer to that is why would
you buy a dac that has such dependence on noise
on usb but i happen to have one deck that it that
i know for sure from testing before that is very
sensitive to the quality of the usb signal it's
an ancient dac from shed the company called modi
ii the company built state of the art products
today but at the time they had built this modi ii
they weren't where they are today and if
you look in here you see the sign ad now
you know drops way down to 73. so we're way
down you can see why the noise floor is quite
high in here and we have a series of distortion
spikes in here and it only puts out 1.6 volts
or so instead of two volts that the other ones
did so we go ahead and plug in jitterbug surely
it cleans up the noise on this guy well no it
even though we have much more elevated noise
we have a dac that's sensitive and the cyanide
didn't change interestingly enough the output of
the stack dropped 0.01 volts not a whole lot but
it dropped 0.1.01 volts which tells me that the uh
the jitterbug is causing enough extra impedance on
the power line to cause the output of the stack to
drop a little bit so it's actually doing something
wrong doing some harm in here rather than doing
some good so no noise been reduced nothing but
you actually lose a little bit of output that
you don't want to lose jitter test is very
sensitive and if you for this to hack and you
can see when i run it what an awful display you
get now this is called broadband random jitter so
it widens the skirt as we call it around our main
12 kilohertz tone this is the only wanted signal
in here this is all unwanted and again we connect
jitterbug to it it makes no difference and uh
you know actually as i come it actually gets a
hair worse why it gets a hair worse who knows
but but it certainly doesn't make it any better um
once again we also just look at the noise spectrum
and you know that's plugged in and and we go
with it without jitterbug and noticing here
that there's just nothing nothing nothing nothing
is filtered whatsoever so objectively we can't
find that it reduces jitter objectively we can't
find that it reduces distortion objectively we
can't figure out that it's it's reducing jitter
either well we figure out that it's not reducing
jitter either so it's really nothing really has
happened but the claim is that well the ears more
sensitive we're not measuring the right things
never mind the company's claims we did measure
but doesn't sound any different so i took this
modi deck that is most sensitive to power line
artifacts and hooked it up to this SMSL SMSL
thx um sp200 which is a state of the art
headphone amplifier based on thx technology so
it's as transparent as you could possibly get
and i use my Sennheiser hd 650 as a
headphone and then i drove the moti 2 direct
excuse me or through jitterbug and i played
my best reference tracks with tons of detail
and everything and the nice thing about
roon was that it was able to recover
when i unplug them plug back things in in about
five seconds able to just continue playing and uh
i heard no difference whatsoever now realize
there are a lot of people who buy these things
if you look at the reviews in here there are
761 reviews four stars on the average so a bunch
of people think they're hearing a difference
and i've explained the reason for that before
because essentially when you change something
in your system you pay more attention and you're
listening more carefully and then you say
wow look at this sounds better sounds more
fluid there's less noise but that's all the
fidelity that was in your source to begin with
and when you take it out you're going to program
yourself into thinking okay this was the reason
it was all improved you plug it in directly
all of a sudden oh yeah without it sounds dull
no it doesn't have a loved one do the tests that
i did behind your back so you can't tell and do
it 10 times if 8 out of 10 times you can tell when
jitterbug gets plugged in when it's not plugged in
and i guarantee you that you will not be able to
pass that test whatsoever you'll be lucky four or
five times you get it right and if you get it four
or five times and it's basically randomly guessing
so all the obvious improvements that you
heard and if it's that obvious you should
you should be able to get 10 out of 10
you're not going to get 10 out of 10
or remotely so or these guys would sell millions
of these things on this thing now sometimes i do
tear downs on these and but these come kind of
glued together so but luckily i have a Samoyed
dog that found this jitterbug that i owned and
managed to chew it up and do a tear down for me
remarkably the unit worked perfectly um nothing
was damaged despite the case and you can see
some of his white hairs stuck to this and uh so we
now courtesy of our dog you get to see what's in
it and i think i'll have a zoomed up picture of it
in here if you look in here all you're seeing the
l means an inductor and c means a capacitor
so basically this is just a low-pass filter
that's put in around data and or power line and
uh that's fun and dandy but there's a problem with
cleaning up the data lines the usb bus is running
pretty high speed so these pulses are coming
you can't filter that because if you filter those
pulses the pulses get rounder and they actually
cause problems building well being
able to extract that data correctly
so filtering is not your friend necessarily
now you could filter frequencies that are way
above the what the digital receiver wants and in
that case a good thing but boy you're filtering
very very high frequency rf that doesn't make it
into the device anyway and power line filtering
yeah you could you know that's dc so the five volt
that's on usb bus you could filter that but the
question for you is this why do you think somebody
designing a dac that knows full well is going to
be hooked up to a pc that's noisy pc wouldn't put
these three cents worth of parts inside your deck
think about it what is that designer that stupid
that didn't know that this is all you had to
do put this little few parts in there and bam
jitter goes down sound is no longer flat it's not
irritating anymore this is all it took a couple
of inductors and capacitors don't you think these
capacitors inductors are really inside your
deck the deck never runs off of that 5 volt
input that comes in it takes a 5 volt input
it's only positive but the dac many times needs
both positive and negative so it regenerates the
negative using a switching power supply usually
well always if it needs it and even the positive
they don't they want they don't want five volt
usually runs at 3.3 volts or maybe even higher
voltage for the output stage so the 5 volt is like
a raw input that comes into the dac the dac that
regenerates it into a dc and then filters that dc
so what it gets is extremely filtered that's
what the good tags that i test i test them on
this noisy gaming style workstation i have
and i've tested it on other computers that
i've had all high performance stacks generally
the same noise same distortion as i've shown you
and it absolutely does not make a difference
why because any designer knows what they're
doing builds a proper dac knowing that the
usb bus signal is noisy and you got a filter
and if you could use a charger the dongle that
dongle is also not going to be the cleanest power
so all of this technology is already in there why
spend 69 on this you could buy a whole deck that
doesn't have any usb dependency for 69 bucks why
would you go spend money on something like this so
just know that there is no magic in
it there's nothing really in here
you're paying for manufacturing of this thing the
patch you're getting packaging it's shipping it
to you amazon takes their card all your quest
takes they got whoever made the sticks they cut
so and i don't want to just go after
audio quests i've tested the other ones
um so one other one is this ifi um does uh
micro i usb 3.0 this one's quite expensive uh
is 400 and somebody sent this to me for
testing and same story i won't bore you
although before i get there there's something on
their website i think when i look that he says
this is who's it for is this for systems
that are more than fifteen hundred dollars
it's kind of a snobbish statement that if your
system's too cheap this is not good for you
but anyway i do have expensive system a few would
sit on it makes no difference anyway i won't bore
you with all the measurements uh but here we
have much better text to test with because
time's gone by and it's a much newer review you
can see that i got 118 db synapse of topping d90
and if i use it with a usb it makes no
difference but it's got a little switch
where you can float the ground that can be useful
actually um because you can get ground loops
but when you flip that up where you're floating
the usb bus you actually generate new error that
didn't exist at 18 kilohertz and you can see that
in here or 16 kilohertz um so don't go floating
the ground thinking that it always does some good
it you know doesn't necessarily do any good so
you know these companies i'm sure will be up in
arms seeing this this write-up and my answer to
them is what i'll put in here if you think it's
any better than this show me the measurements
or show me a blind listening tips don't say we've
sold 100 000 of these things it doesn't matter you
can sell anything to anybody uh on this thing um
just make some claims and make people believe the
claims and then go plug it in and as i explained
it's just human nature when you go buy something
new and plug it in and you know you're gonna want
it to uh sound better and it will or even if you
don't think it's gonna sound better you can
still fall prey to what i explained as far as
your mind changing and looking at these things so
please don't spend your money on these things um
if there's a new one and by the way i've tested
other ones that i'm not going over if you go to
audiosciencereview.com and search for these
things you'll see that i've tested others and
it's just the same story repeats over and over
again uh if if there's a new one and you think
their claims are valid you're in us send it to
me i'll run these tests i'll listen to them and
we'll get that data but for now based on years of
testing these things and the fact that the whole
concept of what they do is faulty they absolutely
positively do not do anything useful they don't
do it useful they don't do it electrically they
don't do it by measurements and they don't do it
for your ear either so don't fall prey to oh you
know we don't measure the right things well i've
listened and listened properly and it absolutely
makes no difference okay thanks for stopping by
and hope you enjoyed this debunking review or
article or video and see you in the next one bye